language rules for movie stars is a
common practice on the sets of all your
favorite movies and shows and that
includes the faces behind these iconic
marvel heroes so if you come with us
you're a wanted man
almost all of the stars behind these
iconic roles are required to stay in
tip-top superhero shape chris hemsworth
ate meals every three hours and stuck to
more classic workout routines such as
pull-ups rows and squats robert downey
jr focused on weightlifting training
while chris evans also started with
weightlifting but soon transitioned into
plyometrics and gymnastic exercises on
top of that florence pew did a lot of
resistance training to play elena in
black widow while kumail nanjiani
focused on changing his diet and working
on different muscles each day to play
kingo in eternals tom holland already
had plenty of experience in gymnastics
when he was cast as spider-man he also
used a machine that relied on electronic
muscle stimulation to get into
spider-man's shape but you work out
while you use it i basically cheated
over the years marvel studios has gotten
even more privy to secrecy than they had
before elizabeth olsen revealed that in
order to even read the script in its
entirety the actors are required to turn
in their cell phones before entering a
private room specifically designed for
scripts these rooms are completely
windowless and the actors were required
to enter alone and they were only
allowed to enter the room once many of
the actors were even given fake scripts
that contain completely different ending
while filming eternals sama hayak
revealed that a man dressed in a trench
coat would appear at her house every
night with new pages of the script in a
manila envelope in exchange for the
previous day's pages marvel sure knows
how to stay covert there's gotta be
some
it's crazy who can forget when mark
ruffalo spoiled infinity war a year
before the movie came out never a good
thing i'm just saying in these movies no
where all the times tom holland
accidentally let something slip well
marvel keeps a close guard on all of
their star's interviews in case any of
them slip up in fact even loki star owen
wilson got in trouble when he revealed
in an interview prior to the show's
debut that his character would have a
mustache once the interview went public
he received an ominous text that read
strike one which wilson thinks could
have been from one of kevin feige's
burner phones no marvel movie is really
complete without a momentous marketing
campaign including merchandising toys
and tie-ins with restaurants foods and
different companies because of this the
stars are required to sign their
physical likeness away so that their
character can be used for these
particular types of promotional material
did you get that after a disastrous
fallout with their original hulk edward
norton over their sophomore feature the
incredible hulk marvel requires the
actors to relinquish their creative
rights behind the scenes this is so the
actors will get along better and
collaborate efficiently with the
directors behind the films instead of
taking control this doesn't prevent them
from having input into their characters
but it is a rule that is in place so
marvel will not have another norton
situation again
there are plenty of movie stars out
there who are keen to perform their own
stunts in their movies there's been
several of the marvel stars who have
also wanted to truly feel like the
heroes they play but marvel much prefers
that they keep the stunt work to the
professionals in fact because of the
substantial insurance premiums the most
dangerous stunts on set are left
exclusively to the professionals and not
the movie stars are we doing that when
the actors and actresses sign on to join
the mcu their contracts go for a
specific amount of movies which includes
cameo appearances this means that if one
of the stars is needed to make a quick
appearance in another marvel flick they
are contractually obligated to appear
which means they can't say no this is
why we've seen stars such as chris evans
popping up in spider-man homecoming and
benedict cumberbatch in thor ragnarok
much like their big screen counterparts
the stars of the marvel cinematic
universe also have to travel across the
globe when doing press for their movies
the stars have to make sure they have
their schedule cleared even after
filming a project as for every movie
they appear they embark on a long and
strenuous press tour in various types of
venues in cities and countries all over
the world
hi would you mind taking a picture with
us oh
sure
vin diesel fans assumed his role was
very limited as his character grew only
mudders three words
well he also said we are groot one time
so that would make it five words
according to diesel himself he was
required to utter those three words
thousands of times in order to capture
different emotions of the lovable
walking trade during numerous scenes in
order to help him with this task he was
given a special script that had the
actual translation of what his character
was really saying
[Music]
when it comes to casting the heads at
marvel want to ensure the actors aren't
carrying any weird baggage with them
that could cause drama down the line tom
von lawler who played ebony ma in
avengers infinity war and end game
revealed that marvel vetted him before
officially signing him on they didn't
know me so when i went over there they
were meeting me for the first time in
fact marvel does background checks on
all of their actors and actresses to
make sure that the stars wouldn't stir
any undesirable press that would
correlate back to the studio
almost every single major blockbuster
that comes out of hollywood has to
undergo reshoots at some point during
post-production this means that the
actors and actresses who appeared in the
movie will have to return to their roles
for additional days to weeks of filming
even if they are already working on
something else idris elba had to learn
this the hard way when he had to step
away from the set of the biopic mandela
a long walk to freedom to once again
play heimdall for reshoots of thor the
dark world as exciting as it may be for
an actor or actress to join the mcu
there are times where they are required
to keep completely quiet about their
involvement in the film to leave room
for surprises when the film finally
debuts such was the case for evan
peter's memorable role in wandevision as
well as jamie foxx who was asked to take
down an instagram post he made
referencing his involvement in
spider-man no way home
big fan spider-man yeah we'll talk about
it later while marvel already requires
its actors to maintain their health and
fitness to step into their super heroic
roles there's also other rules they must
follow in fact marvel requires its
actors to partake in lengthy extensive
training processes as well as practicing
their fight choreography when preparing
for their big roles
the late chadwick boseman did martial
arts training in order to prepare for
his fight scenes as king t'challa in
black panther but it wasn't just
fighting that he had to train for as he
had to work with dialect coaches to
perfect t'challa's wakandan accent
instead of just having an american or
british accent you seem to be doing all
right so far for the characters that
aren't cgi but still look otherworldly
such as karen gillen nebula or dave
bautista's drax the actors are required
to endure an hours-long makeup routine
every day of filming gillen even had to
shave her trademark red hair when she
first starred as nebula in the 2014
guardians of the galaxy even when
they're not playing do-gooders on screen
marvel still wants their superhero stars
to act like a true superhero off screen
the studio strongly encourages its stars
to partake in philanthropy from visiting
kids in hospitals fulfilling the wishes
of make-a-wish kids or partaking in
public outreach this shows the faces
behind these characters can truly live
up to the disney image and then on my
belt is where i keep my extra web
cartridges which go in here when i run
out playing a marvel superhero or super
villain seems like a dream come true but
just because these stars played
characters with great gifts doesn't mean
there weren't rules in place it's like
the classic saying goes with great power
comes great responsibility
[Music]
you